Le prince Hussein a demandé à l'homme pourquoi le
tapis qu'il souhaitait vendre était si
cher celui qui rend le
flyer en carbone tangu mon prince celui qui est assis sur
ce tapis
peut être transporté dans les airs en un
instant
il y a en fait une ligne et un livre d'un
historien appelé  Faisceau CW et c'est à partir d'une
lettre qui lui a été écrite par l'
homme qui était chargé de nettoyer les
champs de bataille et d'identifier les corps
son nom était le colonel un colonel gaucher
Cyril Hughes et cette ligne était un vieil
homme a réussi à arriver ici  d'Australie
aujourd'hui à la recherche de la tombe de son fils, nous nous sommes
occupés de lui du mieux que nous pouvions et nous l'avons
mis sur un bateau pour Brindisi
maintenant cette ligne vient d'exploser dans l'esprit
de l'écrivain, il lisait en fait
ce livre de faisceau CW en recherchant un autre
projet, puis il  l'a
tellement intrigué qu'il a passé environ deux ans à
rechercher et à essayer de découvrir qui était
cet homme et entre lui et son
partenaire d'écriture, un andron local McKnight
Andrew Knight, ils ont juste  rétro-
ingénierie d'un récit pour respecter la ligne
afin que vous ayez affaire à quelque chose qui est,
vous le savez, dans la bataille de Gallipoli, une
pierre de touche culturelle massive pour l'
Australie et la Nouvelle-Zélande,
c'est la première fois que des gens
de notre bout du monde partent en guerre
sous leur  propre drapeau de sorte qu'il
reste encore aujourd'hui une icône culturelle très importante
et l'opportunité pour moi
de prendre cette histoire que tout le monde
pense connaître et de trouver une manière différente de
leur raconter une manière différente de les
informer une manière différente de
leur montrer réellement l'autre point  de
vue qu'ils n'ont jamais pris c'était mon travail
de voler mes garçons pour gérer je les ai trouvés
vous pouvez trouver en était vous ne pouvez même pas
trouver vos propres enfants trois fils tués
j'étais toute une épreuve pour Eliza j'en trouve
assez je  Je le trouverai et
je l'élèverai.  je vais  n téléphone vient j'ai
tué pourquoi Gaddy papasano téléphone si tu
de Montcalm Hongki tard ne fais pas Paula
mère alors épouse moi L papa Lefebvre Asano
téléphone en tant qu'associé de pour te tuer
cash je reviens avec quelques frais un
ami citrons sur paire  un
gâteau de réponse de basse calicot
oui à l'éclaboussure de la ville rangée pourrait mettre cela dans
le lieu réalisable de Bama une
stratégie plébéienne horizontalement Joshua présente une
chanson qu'il montre complète Mon Papa
brevetera sur pallidal nous mettons les citoyens étrangers anémiques
sont des solutions communes para
para comprar L'ASEAN a tenu  sur de la
fantaisie
donc il est vivant je ne sais pas mais votre maison
oups une nécessité d'où je viens ils
ne peuvent pas donc Dieu non il va mr.  Khanna personne
ne me dira ce qui ne se passera pas après
ma mort le Vidya
J'ai promis à une mère que je les trouverais et les ferais
sortir
Je mesure un homme à quel point il aime ses
enfants et non à ce que la grenouille a fait
aujourd'hui
si vous le faites  trouve toi que
lui
dis tu